actually there is a study also that
shows that men with cats in their dating
profiles do not get matches as much they
don't i'm telling you they don't
that's a man that knows how to work for
love i'm damona hoffman and i am the
love expert of the drew barrymore show
and i'm going to expertly tell you which
dating scenarios are green flags and
which ones are red flags
[Music]
if they ask you out but don't attach
concrete plants that's a red flag you
need specificity if you're actually
going to move offline and into the real
world canceling plans last minute
they're a red flag all over them red
flags if they lie about their height on
a dating app that's it's not really a
red flag it's not a green flag but
everybody lies about something so try to
give them the benefit of the doubt if
they ask about previous relationships on
a first date
that's a red flag if they are
so concerned with your baggage that they
can't connect with you you don't want to
be with them if they haven't been in a
relationship that's not a red flag it
just shows that they were waiting for
you if they are extremely close with
their family that's a green flag you
want somebody with secure attachments
this is great if they're judgmental of
your tv tastes red flag they should be
judgmental of anything you're just
meeting them if they're close with their
exes that's a green flag it shows that
they are mature they're able to talk
through their problems and that things
will still be positive even if they
don't end up in long-term romance for
you if they're not necessarily rude to
the waiter but they're a little
dismissive it's still a red flag pay
attention to how your date treats the
people around them because down the road
when they get comfortable that's how
they're going to treat you they order
deviled eggs as an appetizer red flag ew
deviled eggs are gross
it's very confusing because they're too
big for one bite but if you bite in the
middle and you get egg in your teeth
come on red flag
if they order in the language of the
cuisine i think that's a green flag it
shows they're worldly they want to get
to know other people other cultures
that's good as long as it's not like
cultural appropriation
then you might want to think twice
truth hurts that's what lizzo said if
they want to deny ever meeting on an app
oh my gosh my husband and i actually did
that we were so nervous to tell people
that's how we actually met but it's not
necessarily a bad thing anymore people
love to blame the app for the their
dating challenges but if the app is just
the tool
and if you don't have good skills to
communicate to meet someone in person
you're not going to do well on an app or
off an app but don't blame the app just
level up your flirting skills if there's
a ton of food and there are a bunch of
leftovers but they don't want to get a
to-go box red flag that's lunch for
tomorrow
if they don't put their phone away
that's a major red flag even the
presence of a phone on a table during a
date studies show that it can breed
mistrust between you and the person
sitting across from you so put your
phone away and just connect if your dog
doesn't like them
red flag you know dogs are psychic and
they can tell things that we can't why
is it just bad dogs because nobody likes
cats
if they mention more than two
accomplishments from high school
red flag what have you done for me
lately i'm damona hoffman the love
expert of the drew barrymore show and if
you have a question about what's a green
flag and what's a red flag leave your
question below
[Applause]
[Music]